Una rueda gira a 0.35 revoluciones por segundo.
La relación entre el número de revoluciones,
"r" y el número de minutos, no segundos,
transcurridos "m"
se muestran en la gráfica de abajo.
¿Cuál de los enunciados describe la relación
entre las unidades mostradas en la gráfica?
Lo primero que quiero hacer es ver si esta
gráfica hace sentido,
si es consistente con el giro de la rueda a 0.35 revoluciones por segundo.
Y para ver esto, dado que este eje del tiempo
está en minutos, voy a transformar
estas 0.35 revoluciones por segundo,
en revoluciones por minuto.
Así es que queremos convertir 0.35 revoluciones
por segundo, en revoluciones por minuto,
es decir, queremos multiplicarlo por algo que
tenga unidades que sean segundos por minuto,
para que entonces se cancelen estos segundos
y así obtenga revoluciones por minuto.
Pero sabemos que 60 segundos equivalen a 1
minuto y aquí vemos que dado que 60 segundos
y 1 minuto son esencialmente lo mismo, aquí
estaríamos multiplicando por 1,
al multiplicar las 0.35 revoluciones por segundo por 1, logramos que la cantidad en sí, no se altere.
También podemos pensar que lo estamos multiplicando
por 60 segundos por minuto, es equivalente.
Y esto, ¿qué nos va a dar?
Se cancelan los segundos y nos queda,
60 que multiplica a 0.35
y esto ya está en revoluciones por minuto.
¿Y esto cuánto nos da?
60 por .3, 6 por 3 = 18 y 60 por .05 equivale
a 6 por .5, la mitad de 6 son 3
más 18 que teníamos, esto es igual a 21,
esto equivale a 21 revoluciones por minuto.
¿Y esto es consistente con
lo que muestra la gráfica?
Veamos, después de 2 segundos,
deberían de ser 42,
bien, sí, está ligeramente arriba de 40
y después de 5 segundos
debería haber girado 105 revoluciones,
sí, si está correcto,
así que la gráfica es consistente con esta información.
Ahora veamos cuál de estos enunciados es correcto.
Las unidades de la pendiente serían las mismas
si el eje "x"estuviera en revoluciones y
el eje "y"estuviera en minutos.
Así que recordemos qué es lo que es la pendiente.
La pendiente... la pendiente se define como
la razón del cambio de eje vertical,
la razón de cambio del eje "y"
con respecto al cambio en el eje "x",
Así que, la manera como se determina la
pendiente en esta gráfica,
es la razón de cambio de las revoluciones "r" con respecto al cambio en el tiempo, en los minutos, o "m".
No me gusta usar "m" porque
se confunde con metros,
pero fue lo usaron aquí para designar el eje horizontal.
Así es que, en este caso, la pendiente es
cuando ha cambiado el tiempo en una unidad,
¿cuánto ha cambiado el número de revoluciones?
Digámoslo así, ¿qué ha pasado cuando ha
cambiado un minuto?
Cuando ha cambiado el tiempo en 1 minuto,
el número de revoluciones han cambiado en 21, en 21.
Así es que la pendiente aquí es
21 revoluciones por minuto.
Esa es la pendiente de esta recta... la pendiente
de esta recta es igual a 21.
Si cambiamos les ejes, si hacemos el eje vertical
tiempo y el eje horizontal revoluciones,
entonces la pendiente sería el recíproco de esto,
sería la razón del cambio en el tiempo
con respecto al cambio en las revoluciones,
sería 1 entre 21.
Así que definitivamente, las unidades de
la pendiente no serían las mismas.
Así es que ese enunciado no aplica.
Una gráfica conteniendo esta información
podría usar revoluciones y horas.
Claro, tendríamos que cambiar la escala,
pero pensemos un poco en esto...
pensemos en esto.
Definitivamente sí podríamos tener una gráfica
donde el tiempo, el eje horizontal estuviera en horas.
Actualmente tenemos 21 revoluciones por minuto,
pero si lo multiplicamos por 60,
vamos a tener revoluciones por hora, hagámoslo.
Tenemos 21 revoluciones por minuto y las vamos
a multiplicar por 60 minutos que hay en 1 hora.
Y estos minutos se cancelan y nos queda 21
por 60, veamos, 20 por 60 son 1200 más 60
=1260 revoluciones por hora.
Así es que definitivamente si podríamos
construir una gráfica que contuviera esa información,
si este es nuestro ejes de horas,
aquí podríamos tener 1 hora, 2 horas,
3 horas, este es nuestro eje de horas.
Y aquí tendríamos revoluciones, podríamos
tener una escala de mil en mil,
aquí tendríamos 1000, luego tendríamos
2000 revoluciones.
Entonces cuando hay 0 horas hay 0 revoluciones,
a una hora hay 1260 revoluciones más o menos por ahí,
esta sería aproximadamente la gráfica
pero lo que nos interesa es que, sí, definitivamente
si se pude mostrar la información usando
revoluciones por hora.
Finalmente, la tasa a la cual la rueda gira
es el número de revoluciones
dividido por el número de minutos.
Por supuesto, en este caso la tasa, dado que
el eje vertical son revoluciones
y el eje horizontal son minutos, la tasa es
la pendiente de la recta.
Por lo que, la tasa de cambio y las revoluciones
con respecto al tiempo
así como está puesto en esta gráfica, está dada en revoluciones por minuto.
Así por ejemplo, si las revoluciones cambian
de este punto a este punto de acá,
la tasa de cambio sería, el cambio en "r", el cambio
en revoluciones sobre el cambio en el tiempo,
sobre el cambio en minutos, así es que es
cambio en revoluciones
dividido entre cambio en minutos.
Así es que esta respuesta también es correcta.